il ya un peu plus d'un an un mystérieux
virus est détecté dans la ville chinoise
de wuhan
très vite le sar skov de envahi le monde
entier et soulève de multiples
interrogations
d'où vient-il qu'en est il exactement
apparu si sa provenance demeure
incertaine la communauté scientifiques
estiment que l'animal à l'origine du
virus serait la chauve souris
celle ci aurait transmis le sar skov de
o pango l'un un petit mammifère
d'afrique et d'asie du sud-est qu'il
aurait à son tour transmis à l'homme
mais d'autres théories souvent
controversées circulent au printemps
dernier donald trump martelait que le
coc vie 19 avaient pu accidentellement
s'échapper d'un laboratoire de houran
notre pays comme la france reproche à
pékin un manque de transparence sur sa
gestion de l'épidémie
des accusations démenties par la chine
pour les milieux complotistes le virus
aurait même été créé volontairement en
laboratoire des théories balayé par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
l'instance internationale appelle à se
baser uniquement sur la recherche
scientifique
nous voulons connaître l'origine du
virus et nous ferons tout pour cela s'il
vous plaît ne politisent et pas cette
question
nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons en
nous appuyant sur la science ce qui a
constitué un obstacle et ceux qui a
tenté de nous éloigner de ce que nous
avons fait scientifiquement c'est la
politisation de l'étude de l'origine du
virus par certains lots oms espèrent
envoyer le plus vite possible une équipe
internationale d'études haouran pour
comprendre comment l'épidémie à démarré
et prévenir d'autres introductions de
virus dans la population humaine